President Trump says he and his team
have done something very special
taking full credit for ending turkeys
offensive in Syria after all of the
precious blood and treasure America has
poured into the deserts of the Middle
East I am committed to pursuing a
different course one that leads to
victory for America and now people are
saying wow what a great outcome
congratulations
Stu early to me to be congratulated but
we've done a good job we've saved a lot
of lives the self praise belies the fact
that it was President Trump who cleared
the way for the offensive prompting a
barrage of complaint and usually from
fellow Republicans Senator Graham are
you optimistic about the cease fire
I am optimistic I taught with the
Turkish ambassador that this will hold
but the hard work begins what's to say
some look like we're not gonna tolerate
ethnic cleansing of the Kurds having
acquiesce Trump is now portraying
himself as international peace broker
while continuing to hammer home is
America first message saying let someone
else fight over this blood-stained sand
other players are certainly happy to
step in
Vladimir Putin struck a deal with
President Erdogan that will push Kurds
out of territory just south of Turkey's
border which means Russia will control
areas once held by the Kurds formerly
allied with the US but Trump isn't
wasting any time on the complexities
he's painting this as a straight-up
success which is much needed when you're
in the middle of an impeachment inquiry
that's heating up by the day closed-door
testimonies from a number of high-level
national security officials and
diplomats are painting an increasingly
stark picture of a sub foreign policy on
Ukraine geared towards Trump's own
personal interests in his simplified
message the president claims that a
small number of Kurdish held Isis
fighters escaped and have largely been
recaptured
but his defense secretary mark Esper
says over a hundred are still free he's
been in baghdad ironing out another
contradiction over whether US troops in
Syria actually have permission to move
to Iraq as the Trump administration
claimed this is a u.s. foreign policy
scramble once again forced to dance to
the ever-changing tune of it's impulsive
leader Amanda Walker Sky News Washington